[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAUTA: I am Dr. Walle Nauta.
We have now arrived at the third
tape in our brain dissection
course, in which
we will be dealing
with the cranial nerves.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The same ventral
aspect of the brain
that gave us such a good view
of the great arterial vessels
supplying the brain--
that same ventral surface--
will also show almost the entire
contingent of cranial nerves
leaving or entering the brain.
Let us try to identify some
of these cranial nerves.
Here again, it is
a bit of a problem
to do it before the
arachnoid has been removed.
But if we postpone it until
after the arachnoid has
been removed, we risk losing
the more fragile rootlets
of some cranial nerves.
That is why a preliminary
survey of the cranial nerves
is most usefully
done at this stage.
Let us have a look
at the cranial nerves
that we can see upon
inspecting the ventral aspect
of the brain.
It will be necessary to look for
these cranial nerves in three
different brains.
It is quite rare
to find all of them
intact and optimally
demonstrable
in a single brain--
so you would understand
if, from time to time,
the specimen is
going to be changed.
Starting at the caudal
end of the brain,
at the spinomedullary
junction, we
note that many cranial
nerves make their exit
or enter in the most posterior
parts of the brainstem
and the rhombencephalon.
The most important
orienting line
is this border line here
between medulla oblongata
and the pontine protuberance.
Then we start at that line,
the so-called pontomedullary
sulcus--
we can count three
great cranial nerves.
The one closest to
the midline is here,
this is the abducens nerve.
Somewhat farther out
laterally, emerging
through the same deep
groove between the pons
and the medulla oblongata, is
number VII, the facial nerve.
And finally, if I were
to start laterally,
here is a double
nerve that is actually
composed of the cochlear nerve
with the vestibular nerve.
I have it here, and I hope
it is somewhat visible.
It is this double nerve here,
number VIII, the nervus octavus
or statoacusticus.
VI, VII, and VIII,
abducens, facial,
and statoacusticus here.
If you now go in a straight
line down from that grove here,
we encounter--
close to the midline--
a cranial nerve that
is characterized
by appearing on the surface
in quite a large series
of little fascicles
of rootlets here.
This is cranial nerve number
XII, the hypoglossal nerve.
The hypoglossal nerve, as you
can rather clearly see in this
specimen, emerges from just
underneath this olive-shaped--
this overt bulge here, the
so-called inferior olive.
On its medial side here
runs the pyramidal tract.
It is through that groove
between the olivary bulge
and the pyramid, that the
hypoglossal nerve makes
its exit from the brainstem.
It is a pure motor nerve
that innervates the tongue.
A little bit farther
laterally here,
through the side of
the medulla oblongata
and taking their exit
through a line quite a bit
dorsal to the olivary
prominence here,
are two further nerves: IX,
the glossopharyngeus here,
and its immediate
caudal neighbor--
the somewhat larger nerve--
that we call nervus
vagus, IX and X here.
Let me count the nerves once
more here, name them by number.
Here in the pontomedullary
grove from medial to lateral:
the abduncens nerve
here, the facial nerve--
number VII-- and
this double nerve,
the statoacoustic nerve--
composed of the cochlear
and the vestibular nerve--
here.
Just behind that VIII nerve
emerges cranial nerve number
VIIII, the glossopharyngeus.
And immediately in line
with it and like it,
emerging through the lateral
surface of the medulla
oblongata, is the vagus,
number X. Here is number XII--
and you may now ask,
where is number XI?
Where is the 11th cranial nerve?
The 11th cranial nerve
is a most devious one.
It is actually, to the
largest extent at least,
a spinal cord nerve.
However, in its course, it
enters the cranial cavity
through the foramen
magnum, and it
emerges in the company of the
glossopharyngeus and the vagus
through a common opening in
the base of the cranial cavity,
the so-called jugular foramen.
IX, the glossopharyngeus,
X, the vagus, and XI,
the accessory nerve
here, emerge together
from the cranial cavity
through the jugular foramen.
You see here, only a short
stretch of the accessory nerve.
I must pull the vertical
artery a little bit
toward the medial
side to show it.
This nerve, here running
alongside the spinal cord
really, is not in the typical
position of a ventral root
of the spinal cord--
here is a ventral root
nor does it correspond
in its line of exit
to a dorsal root
of the spinal cord.
It follows an intermediate
position here,
emerging from the
side of the upper five
to six spinal cord segments.
These rootlets of
the accessory nerve
join each other into this
longitudinal strand here,
that then quite anomalously--
quite atypical for a
spinal cord nerve here--
enters the cranial cavity
through the foramen magnum.
Now I'll just quickly review
these cranial nerves again.
Through the pontomedullary
sulcus emerge cranial nerve
VI-- the abducens--
VII-- the facial--
VIII-- the statoacoustic
nerve here.
Going straight back from
the nerve number VIII--
the statoacoustic--
emerge the cranial nerves,
IX, the glossopharyngeus here,
and immediately
associated with it
on the caudal side, the somewhat
larger cranial nerve number X,
the vagus.
Cranial nerve number XI
originates from the spinal cord
and joins IX and X
from the caudal side
to leave the cranium
through the jugular foramen.
Here, as the only
nerve to emerge
from below the olive,
the hypoglossal nerve
with its many
rootlets here, that
come together to form the
quite substantial motor
nerve innervating the
tongue musculature.
This small territory here of
the upper medulla oblongata
and to lower border
of the pons, really
is the site of exit
of no less than 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 cranial nerves.
By comparison, the other
parts of the brain surface
are really much more sparsely
supplied by cranial nerves.
When I say supplied, I should
have said sparsely used as exit
or entrance by cranial nerves.
However, the largest
cranial nerve--
number V, the trigeminus--
is seen here in a slightly
more forward position entering
the brain through
the brachium pontis,
or the middle cerrebellar
peduncle here.
The trigeminus is very
largely a sensory nerve,
but it has a small
motor component
that sometimes forms a
separate little rootlet here
on the ventral and medial side.
In this particular
case, I can not really
say that I could identify
it with any certainty.
It could be this one,
but I am not sure
at all that that is true.
The fifth cranial nerve,
a most remarkable nerve
that breaks really all
the rules of nerve exit.
Here is the cranial nerve
number IV, the trochlear nerve.
The trochlear nerve originates
from the caudal part
of the midbrain.
It emerges immediately behind
the inferior colliculus.
Through a very anomalous site--
namely the dorsal surface--
there are no other
motor nerves known
to leave either the
brainstem or the spinal cord
through the dorsal surface.
It is really quite unique
to the trochlear nerve.
And then to add an other
peculiarity, at its exit,
it immediately crosses
over to the opposite side,
so that the trochlear
nerve of the left side
innervates the superior oblique
muscle of the right eye.
Let us see if we can
find the trochlear nerve.
It is deeply hidden
here in the depths
of the transverse fissure.
I can show it already,
where it emerges
from around the cerebellum.
It is here.
I might even turn this back
to its original position,
and here is the trochlear nerve.
But its position at the
moment is quite deceptive.
It does not emerge through
the ventral surface
of the brainstem, it comes
from the dorsal surface.
And let us see if we
can follow it there
and identify its
point of origin.
It's a bit risky to pull off
the arachnoid under which it is
covered here, but there it is.
And here we see this
remarkable cranial nerve
as it comes from the dorsal
surface of the midbrain here,
runs circumferentially
over the lateral surface
of the midbrain.
And here appears, on the ventral
side, the trochlear nerve,
number IV.
The trochlear nerve innervates
one of the external eye
muscles.
Another one, the
lateral rectus muscle,
is innervated by
the abducens nerve.
The trochlear nerve innervates
a single external eye muscle,
and that is the
superior oblique muscle.
Then the remainder of the
external eye muscles--
the rectus superior, the rectus
medialis, the rectus inferior,
the obliquus inferior, and the
levator palpebrae superioris--
are all innervated by a single
cranial nerve, the oculomotor.
The oculomotor nerve,
unfortunately in this specimen,
is lacking.
It undoubtedly must
have [INAUDIBLE]
when the brain was lifted up
from inside the cranial cavity.
And we will have to identify
it in another specimen.
If I may ask for
another specimen please.
Thank you.
It is here.
The oculomotor nerve is
really, as you can see here,
an unexpectedly large nerve.
For so little volume
of striated musculature
as it has to innervate, its
size is truly remarkable.
It all indicates that
the innervation ratio--
nerve fiber versus number
of striated muscle fibers--
is really quite high here.
Here, once more, is the
trochlear nerve emerging
from around the midbrain here.
Here is the fifth cranial nerve.
Here is the oculomotor
nerve emerging
just rostral to the
pons from the depths
of the interpeduncular
fossa here,
and making its exit
characteristically
between the superior
cerebellar artery
immediately behind it and
the posterior cerebral artery
immediately in front of it.
This is really the typical
position of the oculomotor
nerve at its exit,
almost pinched
between the two end branches
of the basilar artery--
the superior cerebellar
artery and the posterior
cerebral artery here.
What now remains in the
way of cranial nerves
are two cranial nerves that
were counted as number I and II,
although later it became
obvious that they are not really
nerves in the strict
sense of the word.
The two nerves in question
are cranial nerves I and II.
We find here the structure
that was described
in original
anatomical dissection,
as the first cranial nerve.
This is the olfactory bulb.
This is the olfactory tract.
And here is its attachment
to the ventral surface
of the brain, a region known
as the olfactory trigone here.
You can see the triangular
shape of the area there.
The olfactory tract
inserts itself
to the base of the brain.
This then used to be called
cranial nerve number I. We now
know that it is not
a nerve in the sense
that it develops as part of
the central nervous system,
and not in the form
of nerve fibers
growing out or growing toward
the central nervous system.
Cranial nerve number
II is the optic nerve
that we see here, going
through its hemidecussation--
immediately in front of
the pituitary stalk here
there's a hemidecussation
between the right
and the left optic nerve--
to continue into the
optic tract here.
This too was counted as a nerve,
although since that early time,
it has come to be
recognized that this is not
really a cranial nerve, but part
of the central nervous system.
The retina and the optic
nerve are really outpouchings.
They are everted portions of the
central nervous system itself--
forwarded outposts
of the brain itself,
rather than being a true nerve.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It may be useful
at this juncture--
now that we have seen the
external appearance of some
of the cranial nerves as they
make their exit from the brain
or enter into the brain--
it might be useful
to review briefly
the appearance of these
same cranial nerves
and their nuclei--
their motor and sensory nuclei--
in microscopic slides.
We'll do this very briefly.
It can of course not substitute
for an accurate examination
of the slides in total.
This first level
that you see here
is typical for the
medulla oblongata--
the caudal half or so
of the rhombencephalon.
We see here at the very base of
the brain, the pyramidal tract,
close to the midline.
Lateral to it, the
remarkable configuration
of the inferior
olivary nucleus that
is responsible for
the bulge that we
saw in inspecting the
ventral surface of the brain.
And we see, as we proceed
along the lateral surface,
we see that we come
to a point that there
appears to be a deep valley.
That deep valley is actually the
floor of the fourth ventricle.
The choroid membrane that
forms the roof of the fourth
ventricle cannot be seen here,
because the staining technique
is unable to bring it out.
Our main point at
this level is to show
the relationship of the
hypoglossal nerve that
emerges below the olive.
You see it here, emerging
through the grove
between the pyramidal
tract on the medial side
and the olivary prominence
on the lateral side.
We see it's not a nucleus--
the nucleus from which the
hypoglossal nerve originates,
close to the
midline, immediately
below the floor of
the fourth ventricle.
If we compare that
medial exit, that
is really a very typical
position for a pure motor nerve
to take its exit--
close to the ventral
midline, in the same manner
that characterizes
the motor or ventral
root in the spinal cord--
if you compare it with the
exit point of a mixed nerve,
in this particular
case, the vagus nerve.
The vagus nerve, as
you can see here,
takes a far more lateral exit.
It is almost in the position
within the spinal cord
we would call dorsal root.
And it's cell groups
of origin are several.
Instead of one
single motor nucleus,
the vagus nerve has no
less than two motor nuclei.
The main one is lateral
to the hypoglossal nucleus
in the floor of the
fourth ventricle.
It is known as the dorsal
motor nucleus of the vagus.
A second motor nucleus
is situated more deeply
hidden in the substance of
the brainstem tegmentum dorsal
to the olive, approximately
at this position.
And from these two sources,
axons unite with each other
and together take
their exit through
the lateral dorsal aspect
of the medulla oblongata,
in that characteristic position
in which mixed cranial nerves
exit from the brain.
The vagus nerve-- and much
like the glossopharyngeus,
its immediate
anterior neighbor--
in addition, contains
sensory fibers.
These come in at the
same point, and then they
proceed inside the brainstem to
the so-called solitary tract,
which is shown here.
And from here on,
the distribution
of impulses to the nucleus
of the solitary tract--
and hence to central stations
higher up in the brainstem--
they'll begin.
We see here, in other words--
very clearly illustrated
at this level--
the differential exit zone of
a pure somatic motor nerve--
the hypoglossus--
with a mixed nerve that is
partly motor, partly sensory--
the nervus vagus.
On the next slide, we see
the characteristic entrance
into the brain of a
pure sensory nerve.
The sensory nerve
that is shown here
is the VIII nerve, in
particular, that component
that we call the cochlear
nerve, because it collects
its impulses from the
spinal ganglion, which
in turn picks up its
impulses from the hair
cells in Corti's organ.
We see the nerve here
coming in far lateral
into a lateral and dorsal
zone of the cross section.
We see its two recipient
secondary sensory nuclei:
the ventral cochlear nucleus
and the dorsal cochlear nucleus.
And from here on
then, the path will
continue as a lemniscal pathway
that will ascend, ultimately,
to the inferior colliculus.
This level marks exactly
the pontomedullary groove
that we saw a moment ago in
inspecting the ventral surface
of the gross brain.
If you see here, the
characteristic sequence
of nerves taking their exit
from the ventral surface
closest to the midline
is the abducens nerve--
a pure motor nerve.
And hence, it
should not surprise
us to see it take its exit so
close to the ventral midline.
It too could be compared
to a ventral root
in the spinal cord.
As we proceed
laterally from here,
the next nerve to be
encountered is number VII.
It's clearly shown
in this preparation,
taking a more lateral
exit from the brain.
The seventh nerve
is partly motor--
is largely motor even--
but it contains sensory fibers.
As a mixed nerve it--
just like the vagus nerve
and the glossopharyngeus--
takes its exit or entrance
in a more lateral part
of the brainstem circumference.
The most lateral
nerve to be seen here
is the vestibular nerve.
It is part of the
eighth cranial nerve.
On the interval between the
facial nerve and the purely
sensory vestibular nerve, you
see an extra little nerve.
This extra little nerve is
known as the nervus intermedius
of Wrisberg.
This nerve actually
belongs to the complex
of the facial nerve.
It is composed of
its autonomic motor
fibers and its sensory fibers.
Together, these fibers will--
once they have left the
confines of the cranium--
they will appear as the chorda
tympani in the periphery.
Recapitulating, at
this level we find--
as the medial
element to emerge--
a pure somatic motor nerve--
the nervus abducens--
a mixed nerve--
the nervus facialis-- with
its sensory component here
as separately shown, and then in
the farthest lateral position,
a purely sensory nerve--
the vestibular.
This level is included
in this survey
because it shows the peculiar
mode of exit of the trochlear
nerve.
We are here at the level,
just at the caudal border
of the midbrain.
This region of the
brainstem is sometimes
known as the isthmus--
the narrowest part
of the brainstem.
One sees here only one
cranial nerve emerging,
and quite anomalously, it
emerges from the dorsal midline
of the first crossing
through a thin plate
that forms the
roof of the isthmus
of the cerebral aqueduct.
This thin roof is known as
the anterior medullary velum.
We see the fiber material of the
left and right trochlear nerves
crossing through it
before the nerve emerges
as a peripheral nerve
from the dorsal surface
of this level of the brainstem.
This level of the
midbrain corresponds
to the inferior colliculus.
One sees the inferior colliculus
as a prominent structure
forming the roof
of the midbrain.
Below it, and somewhat
between the left and right
inferior colliculus, appears
the cerebral aqueduct.
Surrounding it is a
ring of gray matter,
the central gray substance.
Immediately below it,
close to the midline,
appears the medial
longitudinal fasciculus.
And nestled in its
dorsal surface,
is the motor nucleus
of the trochlear nerve.
The motor nucleus
in other words,
as you can now understand, lies
a little rostral to the point
of exit of the trochlear nerve.
At this highest level
of the brainstem,
we are in the rostral
part of the midbrain,
and we see much the
same configuration
that we saw in the
preceding slide,
except that the prominent
structure on the dorsal surface
is no longer the
inferior colliculus.
We are now at the level of
the superior colliculus.
Surrounding the
aqueduct, here again, we
see the central gray substance.
Close to the midline, along
the ventral circumference
of the central gray substance--
the medial longitudinal
fasciculus.
And the somewhat
light staining zone,
immediately to the
medial side of it,
is the motor nucleus of
the oculomotor nerve.
We see emerging from that motor
nucleus, numerous rootlets.
We can see them
almost fanning out
through the midline portion--
the medial portion-- of
the midbrain tegmentum.
And throughout the
ventral surface,
we can see how many such
little rootlets combine
to form the exit rootlets
of the oculomotor nerve
that emerges between
the cerebral peduncles
through the
interpeduncular fossa.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BEEPING]
Hello, I'm Dr. Walle Nauta,
and I will be-- you might say--
your tour guide through this
series on the gross anatomy
of the human brain.
The series consists of 15 parts
of rather different lengths.
In a very quick survey, these
various parts or chapters
can be listed as follows.
You will see from this
listing that the first six
parts or chapters of
the series will not
include any actual dissection
in the literal sense of cutting
asunder.
Instead, the first
two parts deal
with the bony and membranous
envelopes of the brain,
parts III and IV on tape 2,
with the brain's blood vessels,
and parts V and VI on tape
3, with the cranial nerves
entering and leaving the brain.
It is only in part
VII on tape 4 that we
will start removing such
surface structures on our way
into the brain itself,
beginning at the cerebral cortex
and proceeding from there--
in tape 5, part VIII--
into the deeper reaches of
the cerebral hemisphere.
The separate tape 6, part IX,
is focused on the temporal lobe.
In parts X on tape 7, and
parts XI and XII on tape 8,
we will deal with
the white matter
of the cerebral hemisphere,
the complexity of which
will make it
necessary to include
in part XII, the survey of some
histological sections stained
for myelin.
Continuing on tape
8, part XIII will
revisit the arterial circle of
Willis at the base of the brain
and expose the
various subdivisions
of the olfactory system.
In part XIV on tape 9,
we will begin our descent
from the forebrain to
the midbrain, a descent
to be continued in the 15th,
and last part, on tape 10
with the dissection of the
hindbrain and cerebellum.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The dura has, in a word, its
own arterial blood supply.
These blood vessels
are understandably
called the meningeal arteries.
The most prominent among them
is the middle meningeal artery,
which we see here with
several branches distributed
over the various parts
of the dural cap.
We can see that this
midline duplicature almost
subdivides the cranial cavity
into a left and a right half.
Obviously, it has to have a
relatively wide opening here
to permit the passage of
connections between the left
and the right hemisphere.
We see that here, this
very deep incisure
between the spinal cord and
brainstem on the one hand,
and the lower surface of the
cerebellum on the other hand,
the arachnoid stretches over,
and thereby comes to form
the cover for a very deep
and large cistern that is
of great practical importance.
This is the so-called
cerebellomedullary cistern,
also called the cisterna magna.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now this vein is often known as
the posterior anastomosing vein
of Labbé.
And one sees that the way
in which the vein's laid out
on the surface of
the cortex virtually
ensures that there are
multiple possibilities
for directional change
of the blood flow.
Then a vein would become
obstructed somewhere
in this area, let us say--
the blood flow would have no
difficulty finding an alternate
route into the middle
superficial vein here
and through Labbé's vein
into the transverse sinus.
We can see here the curve taken
by the anterior cerebral artery
coming from this point here--
the curve around the genu
of the corpus callosum--
and from there on
moving caudally
over the surface of
the corpus callosum.
We'll open this now.
We see here in the depth,
the corpus callosum here.
And with a little
bit of inconvenience,
we can see here one of the
two anterior cerebral arteries
lying on the dorsal
surface of the callosum.
And here laterally, the
middle cerebral artery lying
on the surface of the insular--
quite far away from the brain
surface and communicating
with it only through
secondary vessels coming off
of the lips of
the opercula here.
And finally, the posterior
cerebral artery here,
that is quite
well-hidden in the groove
between the medial
surface of the occipital
and temporal lobes here on
the one hand and the midbrain
on the other hand.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Starting at the caudal
end of the brain,
at the spinomedullary
junction, we
note that many cranial
nerves make their exit
or enter in the most posterior
parts of the brainstem
and the rhombencephalon.
The largest cranial nerve--
number V, the trigeminus--
is seen here in a slightly
more forward position,
entering the brain
through the brachium
pontis or the middle
cerebellar peduncle here.
We are in the rostral
part of the midbrain,
and we see much the
same configuration
that we saw in the
preceding slide,
except that the prominent
structure on the dorsal surface
is no longer the inferior
colliculus-- we are now
at the level of the
superior colliculus.
Surrounding the
aqueduct, here again, we
see the central gray substance.
Close to the midline, along
the ventral circumference
of the central gray substance--
the medial longitudinal
fasciculus.
And the somewhat
light staining zone,
immediately to the
medial side of it,
is the motor nucleus of
the oculomotor nerve.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Here, this gyrus is called
the supramarginal gyrus.
And another one, riding over the
top of this long sulcus here,
that runs the length
of the temporal lobe
and is known as the
superior temporal sulcus.
We see a similar
convolution riding
over the top of that
superior temporal sulcus,
and this is often called
the angular gyrus--
gyrus angularis.
This fusion of the two
sulci, of the two fissures,
is deep enough to cause
a marked prominence
in the medial wall
of the occipital horn
of the lateral ventricle, as
we will see a bit later on.
This prominence is known
as the calcar avis--
the bird's spur.
We see that the hippocampal
gyrus is here, deeply incised
by the fusion of the
parieto-occipital
and the calcarine fissures.
And This leads to
a marked narrowing
of the hippocampal gyrus,
known as the isthmus
of the gyrus fornicatus--
isthmus gyri-fornicati.
We see it here in the depths.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I will take two of these slices
of cortical tissue in sequence,
and then we'll stop
for a moment to look
at the contrast between the
gray matter of the cortex
and the white matter.
And at this point, you will see
how the cingulate fasciculus
reaches the anterior border
of the corpus callosum, which
is exactly here.
This is the so-called
genu, and you can see here
how the fascicular cinguli
bends over the genu
to disappear from view.
It distributes itself there
in the subcallosal component
of the medial cortex.
These chordate
veins-- you see here
how you can follow them
into the collecting channel.
The name of this vein is
the thalamostriate vein.
It used to be called
the terminal vein.
At this point, immediately
behind Monro's foramen,
it makes a sharp curve
medialward here and disappears.
This curve here, immediately
behind the interventricular
foramen--
this curving vein is
known as the venous angle,
and it serves the
neuroradiologist
as an orientation for
the most likely position
of the interventricular foramen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
At this level, we are
approaching the anterior limit
of the pineal gland--
cella media left and right.
Here is the cistern of
the velum interpositum
and two internal cerebral veins
would be positioned about here,
in the process of
coming together to form
the great vein of Galen.
You remember that the
temporal lobe had been
detached by a series of cuts.
One such cut involving
the corpus callosum
and the fornix bundle--
this is the fornix bundle here--
and the other one,
a very deep incision
into the lateral side
of the temporal lobe--
deep enough to penetrate
into the temporal horn.
The gyrus dentatus is
really the ultimate end
of the cortical mantle.
Between Ammon's horn
and the dentate gyrus,
a very complicated
topography exists.
We could perhaps best
sum it up by saying
that the hippocampus essentially
consists of two cortical gyri.
It is not the same
type of cortex
that we would find on
most of-- the complexity
of the brain for
example here, this
cortex we would call neocortex.
This cortex at the
extreme medial edge--
at the medial margin of
the cortical mantle--
is of a different
composition, and it is often
referred to as archicortex--
the arch cortex.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
At this point, one hopes
that the split-brain
will be a favorable one.
It is a rather forcible
pulling one must do here.
And as you see, here the
insular appears, now freed--
at least over its
dorsal part here--
now freed from the
overhanging wall
of the parietal and
frontal operculum here.
One sees that the
insular is composed
of three or four gyri that
are arranged in a fan shape.
But it is not too
difficult to imagine
that this more posterior
part of the optic radiation
here would find its ultimate
distribution in the cortex
surrounding the calcarine
fissure, which can easily
be recognized here.
Part of this radiation, in
other words, goes to the cuneus
here--
this area dorsal to
the calcarine fissure.
And the other part,
the more ventral part,
goes to the lingual gyrus,
which we see appearing here.
This is the lingual gyrus.
Here is the fan here.
In this part, it's called
the internal capsule.
In that part, where it lies now
free off the lentiform nucleus,
here is the corona radiata with
these different radiations,
including the optic radiation
here in the most caudal part.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I will make a somewhat
random cut here,
trying to stay as
much as I can parallel
to the fibers of
the optic radiation.
When we do that and
now open up here,
it is quite clear
that we are looking
into a lateral ventricle.
We see choroid
plexus appear here.
I can easily guess that
what I am looking at here
is the calcar avis.
We see here then, once
more, the carotid artery--
this of the left side,
that one of the right side.
Let us quickly get oriented
in the basal aspect
of the diencephalon.
Here are the optic
nerves undergoing
their hemidecussation.
This is the tuber cinereum
with the pituitary stock
invariably here disconnected
from the pituitary that
remained inside the skull
underneath the diaphragm
of the sella turcica.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Here is the so-called
massa intermedia,
a bridge of gray
matter interconnecting
the thalamus of the left
side with the thalamus
of the right side.
All this is the third ventricle.
Here is its communication
with the lateral ventricle
and here its communication
with the fourth ventricle here.
This is the Sylvian aqueduct.
When we look into the markedly
dilated third ventricle here,
it is clear that in this case,
there is a well-developed massa
intermedia.
The massa intermedia
is not always present.
It appears to be missing in
approximately 10% of humans.
But you see it here, it is
nothing very voluminous,
but it is an interesting
detail of thalamic anatomy.
I now turn the brain on
its side, and at this point
we are beginning to
see the lateral surface
of the midbrain.
We see here, looking at the
thalamus once more from behind,
here is the inferior
colliculus here,
the anterior colliculus
here, the thalamus,
the lateral geniculate body--
This overhanging
large triangular area
of the thalamus, that
lies in the vertex
of the curve of the thalamus,
is the so-called pulvinar.
The name pulvinar meant
pillow, and apparently
those who saw the structure
for the first time
were impressed with it.
It reminded them of a pillow
slung over the back of a chair.
And here we see
it, the pulvinar.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I will cut the midbrain
here at the level
between the superior
and inferior colliculi.
Obviously, this cut would have
to involve the basilar artery.
Needless to say,
what we will find
here just lateral
to the thalamus
is the tail of the
caudate nucleus here.
And quite in general, we see
and are reminded rather clearly
of the fact that this
whole region here
marks the roof of the temporal
horn of the ventricle.
We will now turn our
attention to the posterior
part of the brainstem--
the rhombencephalon
with the cerebellum.
You can clearly see here
the typical configuration
of the dentate nucleus.
It is composed of a strongly
folded membrane of--
it's a sheet of
gray matter here.
And out from its hilus
emerge the myelinated fibers
of the brachium conjunctivum.
Here, the brachium conjunctivum
has left the cerebellum
over this stretch.
Here, it disappears under the
roof of the midbrain tectum
here, and at this
point we see once more
the complete decussation
of the cistern.
The brachium conjunctivum, or
anterior cerebellar peduncle,
is a completely closed cistern.